i've always wanted to introduce uh this
man this way um so i'm gonna do it i now
have my opportunity to do it um on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line
uh is a man when urban meyer said scouts
are lazy he was talking about this man
oh wow
wow is that wrong
all right
i don't know oh he says oh he wasn't
talking about this man i'm being told he
was not
talking about this man
love him on the move the sticks podcast
with bucky brooks my colleague from the
nfl
media group and nfl network daniel
jeremiah how are you dj
well i'm doing great rich just woke up
from a long nap you know i try to get my
12 hours
just like all evaluators right all
scouts you're so lazy
yeah i i i heard the i heard rumblings
of that um that that had taken place
yeah
really you mean scouts talk is that what
you're saying daniel i didn't know that
a little bit yeah
so yeah that's the uh i mean by the way
doug peterson if they say like wasn't
like a seinfeld episode it's like kind
of who you want to follow like that is
the that is the one right there that is
the one you want to follow i mean
because i who says such a thing like
that with scouts in the room daniel who
says that uh i mean you know i don't
know
no no that's not good i know
i i yeah i don't know even how to
respond to it rich it's just still
outside of
of anything i've ever been around or
anybody i've ever been around um
especially if you have any knowledge of
what that you know this the grind of
that specific profession like you have
no clue what you're talking about if
that's your take you know because i was
talking about this yesterday and again
this is the athletic article that that
uh about urban meyer's tenure um in in
jacksonville you know that that um he
didn't know who
aaron donald was um prior to playing the
rams and the same thing that was also
mentioned about jamal adams prior to
playing the seattle seahawks and the
number of people that were responding to
this video on either youtube or twitter
like i had to be facetious he had to be
sarcastic you know um but i don't i
don't know about that daniel you know
yeah i mean i i mean he lived in the
college world for so long and you know
a lot of times and i give him this one
flyer i guess is a lot of times college
coaches don't spend a lot of time
watching nfl football their sundays are
spent trying to get ready for the team
they play the next week so
i can understand that from a college
coach's perspective but some of them
like there's there's you know 30 40 guys
you would think you couldn't help but uh
but know who they were even if you never
flipped on the tv on a sunday all right
well let's get to the here and now then
daniel jeremiah uh what did you think of
the tyreek hill trade
i mean where the hell did that come from
too you know
yeah yeah i'd heard rumblings of it a
few days before it went down and you
know it was kind of like i think rosen
has kind of explained it once the
devante adams trade and contract
happened
then uh that kind of changed their
thinking on what type of a deal they
would accept to go back to kansas city
and once the numbers got where they were
headed i think
kansas city um you know had to make a
tough decision now i talked to another
gm in the league about why in the world
would kansas city move on you know i i
see tyreek hill twice a year doing the
charger games and i know every game plan
starts with him and how you keep him
from beating you on on one play which
he's done so many times
so why in the world would they ever you
know let him leave the building right
and they said look the the mahomes
contract the way it was structured his
base salary is only like a million in
change so there's no that's how you end
up manipulating a salary cap is you can
drop those numbers down bonus people out
amortize it over the length of the deal
um so they didn't really have a lot of
wiggle room and the fact that you had
your left tackle in orlando brown on
that franchise tag there's no wiggle
room that's a big number um that's taken
up a lot of their cap space so it was
just going to be kind of difficult for
them
to do that this year and going forward
they just didn't have a ton of room so
they got some flexibility out of the
deal but that's uh yeah it's not often
you see somebody who's literally the
most dynamic uh
weapon in the nfl that hits the trade
market so i guess you know from for me
uh it's clearly down to the trigger man
in miami more than not touah
so what do you what do you think of what
mike mcdaniel is putting together
and do you think it could also be for
teddy bridgewater too what do you think
i think they're gonna get two i think
they'll get two every opportunity and
you know there's
you know there's two ways to get to a
50-yard completion rich you can throw
the ball 50 yards and have it caught and
the guy gets tackled or you can throw it
three yards and let him run 47 yards
with it and i think they've surrounded
tua with guys that can do the latter i
mean when you think about the weapons
they have with wattle and tyree kill and
you know it's bubble screens it's speed
shovels it's shallow crosses it's slants
like the stuff that he is really good at
you know with his quick hands quick
release he's very accurate underneath an
intermediate i think they're going to
just try and get those guys the ball out
in space and and make the rest of the
league try and tackle them you know get
sick he's another one he's one of the
faster tight ends in the nfl
so they have got a track team around two
of them well i guess and that's what i'm
saying is tyrique going to spend some
time this fall going well pat would have
gotten that to me or man um you know i
pat would have known that's where i was
going with it and and the ball goes
elsewhere and then he'll just count his
zeros going back to the huddle right or
or will there be a time what's more
likely that happening or mahomes going
man
we just we we just missed tyrique
it's it's such a difference maker for us
that that guy's gone what's more likely
do you think to happen this year i think
i think that i think that tyrek hill
chose to to make this happen it was his
choice to kind of leave kansas city and
to go to miami and he went to miami for
location and lunch money and so he's got
a lot of uh a lot of the latter there
he's that's that was his decision pat
mahomes i don't think he made the
decision to move on from tyree kill
right and i think that will have more of
an impact on mahomes and the chiefs it
needs at least initially until they can
kind of figure out how to put some new
pieces together but you know i was
looking at this this morning rich and
kind of saying okay what's a different
angle that maybe we're not thinking and
remember last year how much we talked
about all the too high defense that
everybody played against kansas city
chiefs yes and it it didn't stop them
but it did it slowed it down a little
bit and in some key moments especially
their last game of the year and the
second half where they couldn't get
things going and so i almost think andy
reid's saying hey this is an opportunity
for me to get a bunch of assets we've
got more cap space now we can kind of
recreate a little bit of how we're
playing offense because the quick strike
ability that had been their calling card
was was taken away at least to a degree
last year by scheme and i think this is
andy's you know time to try and get
ahead of the curve which he's made a
career of being ahead of the curve
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show um how do you think matt ryan in
indianapolis is going to play out match
made in heaven and uh clearly an
upgraded carson wentz as you and i were
leaving indianapolis after talking to
frank reich we knew wence was uh it was
only a matter of if and
you know if when and not if so
what do you think about the way that it
all worked out for indianapolis daniel
yeah i think i think they got the
the best option for them and the best
you know value in terms of what they had
to give up was next to nothing so i
think that chris ballard's patience was
rewarded the the place where i will
reserve kind of my take on it
is rich they don't have a left tackle
they don't have a number one wide
receiver they have a they lost a guard
free agency like this is not i mean i
think sometimes we just i hear it this
is the most talented roster in the nfl
like they've got a lot of holes they
need to fill especially when you look at
the way everybody loaded up in in the
conference
so yeah i mean i'm excited for matt ryan
i think that's a it's a it's a great
opportunity for him i think he fits
great with frank um but you know chris
ballard's got some more roster work to
do here he's gonna have to work some
magic to fill some of these spots so
where's mayfield going do you think
what's the conversation on mayfield
right now that you're hearing about
daniel quiet as a church mouse right you
don't hear anything i mean seattle is
kind of the one everybody kind of says
well i can make the most sense out of
that one
but you know i talked to buddies that
have been at all these pro days the
seahawks have been sending you know
folks to all these quarterback pro days
and and talking to some friends he said
that the guys they talk to in seattle
they they're they're really legitimately
excited about drew locke like that's not
that's not just kind of press conference
stuff like this is this is something
that they seem genuinely excited about
so i i don't know if they're going to be
as motivated to do something with baker
either so
i'm running out of running options and
places for him to go
well i'm thinking based on everything
right now um
[Music]
don't you think he's going to be sitting
around waiting until the draft is done
to see who chooses what in the draft who
gets
who in the draft right and then and then
you can flip a draft pick next year you
use your your your capital right now
you'll flip something next year to maybe
get him to compete or back up like
that's legitimately what i'm seeing
right now right i mean don't you think
that that's i i shouldn't say anything
because you know tyree kill got traded
devonte adams got traded for crying out
loud you know i mean who the hell knows
anymore what's up but that looks to me
to be the reality of baker mayfield
situation right now yeah
yeah i mean
the thing is you say okay that's a great
luxury to have somebody with his ability
as your as your backup i mean i think
he's i mean for whatever criticism
people have if baker mayfield went
healthy i i think he's inarguably a top
20 quarterback
um in the nfl i think that's i feel that
way but you what do you do with the
number you get a 18 million dollar
number that's not paying your back a
quarterback you know 18 million dollars
the browns are gonna have to eat a good
chunk of that
um to get this contract moved it's just
all the all the chairs have kind of
filled up i almost wonder if the other
option that we're not thinking of is the
browns don't really have anything out
there if they talk to baker and say hey
it's gonna be
what why don't what why don't you just
come here
where we hey you stay away
you're under you're on our payroll you
don't have to come in
and let's just play out some a little
bit of the pre-season here see what if
an injury takes place or there's some
issues and then what you know we'll get
this we'll either move you before you
know right before the season starts or
we'll release you at that point in time
and that's why again i'm holding up you
can't see i've got the kyler murray uh
um uh agent statement on kyler's
wonderful stationery that's why he wants
to get paid that's why he wants to get
paid now right like you don't want to go
into a fourth year and wind up like
mayfield even though that sounds like a
long shot but who'd have thought at this
point last year after mayfield wins a
playoff game going into his fourth year
for a bronze team that had everything on
the upswing the reigning coach of the
year and everything that we'd be in this
situation right now who knew nobody yeah
yeah and also you had lamar getting hurt
right not having his deal done and you
could say well maybe his value would
have been a little bit higher if he
could have done it previously and he
waited and hasn't been defeated thus far
but uh on that note rich i talked to
somebody of the day that said lamar
jackson has been working his butt off
over the off-season what do you mean uh
and he's he is he is he has dialed in he
has been working he has been throwing
every day he's been he's been getting
with different people to work out like
he is
what i was told this is a very focused
lamar jackson i think you're going to
see a huge year from him no kidding he
wants to bet on him if he wants to bet
on himself
from what i'm hearing i'll i'll i'll
join in on that one he sounds like he's
ready to do the kirk cousins plan you
know like
make make 250 million guaranteed
you know what year by year or guaranteed
contract back guaranteed contract
because don't you think one last on this
situation before we turn to your mock
draft that the way that the desean
watson contract got done that pretty
much every quarterback that's going to
get his second contract because he's
already proven a certain amount of worth
um
guaranteed dollars right like whatever
the conversation was between kyla murray
and steve keim now that everything's
been out there and instagram accounts
have been restored with photographs and
we're all back to our quarters quietly
don't you think that whatever was being
talked about got reset by desean's
contract
all being fully done
i agree with you rich and i think
there's two i never thought i'd see the
days that that have changed um i never
thought i'd see the day where nfl
players would be similar to nba players
in terms of being able to get out of
contracts and choose their next location
i never thought we would see that and
then number two is that you know that
the calling card of of the nfl has been
they don't do guaranteed contracts they
just don't do it don't ask it's not
going to happen well that barrier has
been broken and i i i'm with you i think
those premier guys
i'd be demanding that
and i guess that's the the last one i
lied up we haven't moved on to the draft
chat is that um you know devante adams
is a perfect example of what you just
said he was under a franchise tag right
they got aaron rodgers all signed and
he's coming back
if this was like five ten years ago the
packers would have easily said tough too
bad we'll see you we'll see you in the
summer um you know let's talk long-term
contract between now and july 15th and
if not we'll see you next fall because
aaron rodgers has got a window and
you're coming back and we got your
contractual control that's what a
franchise tag is for and instead he
winds up going to where he wants to go
the vegas raiders it's to get paid
that's unprecedented too that's like an
nba player right
it's a kindler gentler league now rich
we've got i think
we've got some of these younger general
managers that have taken over and
maybe some of the older crustier guys
that uh that would have gone that other
route or are out of the league right now
i don't know it it would not have
happened i'm with you you know 10 15
years ago that would not have happened
like this so i like it i think it's i
think it's great i think it makes your
organization more attractive to people
to come in and say hey we're going to we
want to win we're going to create a
great environment and if it's somehow
you don't want to be here we don't want
people that don't want to be here
so then best team in the afc west right
now now the tyree kills gone devante
adams has landed you know obviously
intimately the moves the chargers have
made we know
denver got themselves russell wilson
what do you make right right now of it
daniel
all right you want to see how a
professional sidesteps a question yes
sir um here here we go um i think the
denver broncos
are the most improved team of this group
like they are going to make the biggest
leap because at the most important
position they made the biggest upgrade
so i i think that that is going to be
the team that makes the the monumental
leap when you look at the other three
teams they were all right there you had
the chiefs that won the division you had
the raiders and the chargers and
basically a plan a tie game
yes so i mean
if they i'll
look it's a lot can happen but this
looks like a three playoff team division
to me when you look at it is just
absolutely stacked
um so i don't know how you i don't know
how you pick a favorite among this group
right now but i could make the case
denver's the most improved and i think
in my opinion tyreek hill leaving the
chiefs is the you know that's huge so
they can maybe come back a little bit
and i think all the other three teams
move forward with the broncos making the
biggest push forward daniel jeremiah
well done here on the rich eisen show
few minutes left with uh daniel uh let's
turn to your mock draft many questions
first of all what the hell does three
point what what the hell does 3.1 mean
what does that mean mock draft 3.0 what
does that mean hey i don't i don't i
don't write headlines rich i got a text
message yesterday yeah that you know
after that trade went down and said hey
the chiefs no no tyree kill they just
acquired one of these first round picks
so you've got to swap out that one pick
yes
i just threw christian watson in there
and apparently that took us from 3.0 to
the first ever 3.1 i've never okay now i
understand so it's you just basically
made one
wrinkle to what's already was out there
as your 3.0 and it's so deep down in the
first round right yeah the pick switched
hands so i had to i had to get in and
again it was so deep down in the first
round that you don't have to this the
domino effect is not significant so i
get it 3.1 so the thing though when you
go through it all
the fact that you've changed out kyle
hamilton from two all the way down to 11
where washington i mean the commanders
would run that card up to the vegas i
mean they might actually start betting
on red you know what i mean like
[Laughter]
they might just go to the casino after
that if they get kyle hamilton at 11.
and you have trayvon walker all the way
up at two with kayvon thibodeaux up to
three
what what uh where did you put that all
together
on on your
i wouldn't i wouldn't spend too much
time on that rich but um come on daniel
sell it look safety safety is the
position that god is valued around the
league is i would appreciate it to be i
think he's my third overall player in
the whole draft
and you just kind of look at the teams
and the priority positions that they're
trying to fill and you talk to people
around the league and say okay that he
he's kind of a candidate that could
slide down a little bit uh but i still
think he's one of the you know three or
four best players in the whole draft but
i think when dir in a league where
darwin james can go 17th then hamilton
could fall to the commanders so
that was my thought on that one
thibodeaux is you know a true wild card
i mean it would not surprise me if he
went anywhere from
you know two and three in those spots to
potentially you know fallen out of the
top ten
um but everything that that you kind of
hear is
that the edge rushers are all going to
go early they're all going to get pushed
up and and everybody's going to try and
grab their guy early so that's why i
think we could see you know what i think
i had what four in the top you know
nine picks or something like that and
we're gonna see those edge rushers go
flying off the board and so that you
have the jets going sauce gardener
fourth overall leaving every offensive
lineman on the board uh available which
i think would make the panthers at six
very happy right like if that's the way
that falls correct both of them yeah
both of them i think when you look at
the teams picking really and the jets
could easily take one of those two guys
right um and plug them in but if the
jets decide to go with the corner and
get a true number one corner and sauce
then you have
uh you know the giants at five with the
with a bad offensive line the panthers
at six who've made some moves but still
not a great offensive line um the thing
with the panthers is
like i keep i kept as i do these i think
okay well there's another quarterback
move coming for them you know at some
point time and they have not been able
to get anything done there and here we
are getting towards the end it doesn't
sound like they're in on on baker
mayfield so
um they're at all these pro days there's
just a lot of smoke there where i was
going to say if there's a team in the
top 10 that was going to do the
quarterback i would think the panthers
would would be the most likely and then
you got picketed 18th to the saints and
then everybody else dropping out i
thought malik willis had a terrific pro
day and you think that if he's sitting
there at 20 the steelers don't take him
you think that willis drops out of the
first round and the same with matt
corral huh right now well i turned i i
turned those in before pro days i don't
think pro days have that drastic impact
on what happens there i put malik willis
to the pittsburgh steelers in the first
two mock drafts i believe so well i i
wanted i wanted to look and see okay if
they decide to go somewhere else what
happens i think this is a great this is
a classic year i don't do trades in
these early mock drafts it's kind of
silly but this is a great year to
come back in the bottom of round one to
get your quarterback you know we've seen
that we've seen that happen in the past
i think that's you know if i was one of
these teams picking up their high i
think i'd want to get a good solid
player in that top ten and then i would
try and maneuver my way back into the
back of one and now you've got you know
you've got a team like kansas city
that's picking back to back i'll be
shocked if they if that isn't a spot for
a quarterback where they trade one of
those back um and somebody comes up for
a quarterback there you've got detroit
who's picking 34 in the second round 32
into the first round that's another spot
where they could take one they have the
ammunition if they wanted to move up to
get one they can move and go get one um
so i think that we see the quarterbacks
on the back half of the first round with
either
people making their own selections or
people coming back up from the second
round to go take these guys to get the
fifth year and then the last one for you
on your mock draft is when uh the the
devante adams trade went down i tweeted
out it's gonna be lit when the packers
don't use any of their picks on a wide
receiver which i've had fun hitting send
on and then you have them uh with their
own first round pick and the one they
got for adams
used both on wide receivers olave and
dotson big ten
ohio state and penn state that would be
what we call a bonanza right for aaron
rodgers giving him two young pups but
terrific players in his dotage right i
mean like that would be
amazing how how how
likely do you think that is daniel oh
probably zero percent chance um
they don't do it but i i in this mock
draft rich i wanted to do i i called it
my gettleman mock last year i talked
about how dave gettleman never trades
back never traded back and then we get
to the draft he's gonna begun traded
back that's right so so maybe this is uh
maybe this is the time to break some
norms i had the uh i had the
philadelphia eagles taking a linebacker
which as our buddy knows that's right
geo geosit for the love of god
for the love of god get us a linebacker
he said that
uh on our combine coverage to howie
roseman that's right okay that's why
that's that's why i want that i said
let's get outside the box a little bit
let's let's let's get away from our
norms give them devin lloyd and then man
the packers devonte adams is a is a such
a special player but you go get two guys
like that with the lava and datsun
together combined you got a chance to
replace a lot of that production okay
very good uh thanks for the call daniel
jeremiah greatly appreciate it
uh we'll chat again soon thanks for the
time appreciate you bud right back at
you hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here